vous avez une chaîne youtube mais vous
ne trouvez pas forcément les bons mots
clés pour pouvoir être positionné pour
trouver les bons mots clés les bonnes
expressions clés il faut utiliser une
certaine stratégie c'est pas très
compliqué il ya une certaine méthode
avoir que je vous expliquais tout de
suite de plus en plus de chaînes y voit
le jour sur youtube et il est difficile
de réussir
je partage avec vous toute mes astuces
et les meilleures techniques pour avoir
plus de vue des abonnés et enfin le
mystère sur youtube
inscrivez-vous à ma chienne est activé
la cloche pour ne manquer aucune vidéo
question du jour dites moi comment est
ce que vous faites vous pour trouver vos
mots clés vos expressions clés sur
youtube
est ce que vous faites une recherche
particulière ou alors est ce que vous
faites des vidéos au feeling en fonction
de ce qui vous vient et de vos
inspirations youtube est extrêmement
concurrentiel et c'est difficile de
trouver les bons mots clés les bonnes
expressions clés pour pouvoir se
référencer pourtant il ya une méthode
très très simple et si vous la suivez
vous allez réussir à gagner des
positions augmenter votre hauteur de vue
convertir les vues en abonnés chez vous
détailler les différentes étapes dans
cette vidéo vous allez voir c'est très
facile
avant même de commencer à chercher vos
mots clés aux expressions clés faut vous
y définit votre niche de quel sujet
parlez vous dans quel domaine avez vous
une expertise ça c'est le point le plus
important pour ensuite pouvoir faire sa
recherche dans ce domaine là rester
cohérent sur votre chaîne ça c'est très
très important il faut que vous pariez
toujours du même sujet en abordant
différents points et en apportant des
conseils cohérent une vraie cohérence et
les gens vont s'abonner à votre cher
parce que vous avez une thématique en
particulier qui répondent à leurs
problématiques et ils viennent chercher
des solutions chez vous identifier les
besoins identifiés les problématiques
répond daisy et vous verrez ça marchera
très bien autre point important regarder
la concurrence une fois que vous avez
trouvé votre niche votre thématique
votre problématique
vous avez forcément identifier des
concurrents ce qui marche le mieux aller
voir un petit peu leur vidéo essayer de
comprendre comment se reconstruire leur
titre quels sont les vidéos qui ont plus
de vue comment ils ont fait pour marcher
et vous verrez c'est pas très très
compliqué il y aura peut-être même des
bonnes idées à prendre chez eux quand
vous regardez une très grande chaîne une
chaîne qui a du succès il ya deux choses
à différencier regarder si les vidéos
ont fait des vues parce qu'ils ont des
abonnés que ces abonnés sont allés voir
auquel cas pour vous c'est pas du tout
la bonne stratégie regardez a contrario
si le compteur d'abonnés est plus bas
que le compteur de vue ça veut dire que
leurs vidéos sont référencés qu'ils ont
trouvé les bonnes expressions clés les
bons mots clés et qu'ils ont réussi à se
positionner et c'est juste
morley dessus vous allez vous focalisez
regarder comment on fait les concurrents
il ya beaucoup de choses à apprendre
d'eux pour commencer votre recherche
vous allez faire trois choses
différentes
la toute première vous allez commencer
par ouvrir youtube
la deuxième vous allez sur votre compte
adwords si vous en avez pas je vous
invite à en créer un ça va être
extrêmement intéressant pour vous et
puis troisième point vous allez sur
google trends pour connaître les bonnes
tendances
il ya une méthode qui est extrêmement
simple imaginons par exemple que votre
niçois dans la recherche de perte de
poids savoir comment allait mieux
comment prendre soin de votre corps et
perdre du poids vous avez tout
simplement dans la barre de recherche de
youtube est par exemple vous allez taper
comment perdre du ventre comment perdre
du ventre ça vous le propose en eau est
derrière vous et tout ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ça vous suggère
des expressions clés sur lesquels vous
allez pouvoir travailler commentaire du
vent de comparaison du point comment
perdre du ventre rapidement comment
perdre du ventre rapidement ça c'est pas
mal c'est l'expression qui est
suffisamment longue et sur lequel y aura
probablement moins de concurrence que
sur com - cadre d'une vente
imaginons par exemple que vous arriviez
à vous référencer sur comment perdre du
ventre rapidement une fois que votre
vidéo sera bien référencés que votre
chaîne aurait augmenté et or a pris je
dirais un certain poids par rapport à
votre thématique vous allez pouvoir
ensuite vous référencer plus facilement
soit des expositions sur les expressions
que courtes comme comment perdre du
ventre
on va chercher pour notre part comment
perdre du ventre rapidement je clique
comment perdre du ventre à pinon vous
voyez que vous avez par exemple kevin
philippe qui a fait un million quatre
cent mille vu thi binh chef il ya deux
ans avec 2 millions 700 mille bon petit
bonus ça pourrait mettre un peu de côté
parce qu'il est très très gros vous avez
ensuite tout comment à 900 milles la
première chose qu'on va faire on va
regarder sur ce qu'est jean philippe qui
a 1 million 400 mille vue est-ce qu'il a
plus d'abonnés que le nombre de vues de
cette chaîne auquel cas cela voudrait
dire que ses abonnés ont pu aller voir
cette vidéo
donc elle se référencent pas forcément
très très bien si par contre il a moins
d'abonnés ça veut dire que cette vidéo
c'est référencés par rapport aux mots
clés en cliquer dessus
kevin philippe combien at-il d'abonnés
kevin philippe il a 38 mille abonnés et
il a fait une vidéo qui a énormément de
vue ça veut dire qu'il a mis en place la
bonne stratégie de référencement
ce qui tend à nous montrer que comment
perdu vente rapidement et une bonne
expression pour se référencer tous cas
les lieux il ya neuf mois
donc ça veut dire qu'en neuf mois une
chaîne qui a trente quatre mille abonnés
à fait quand même 1 million 400 mille
vue c'est énorme ce que je vous
conseille mois dans votre avis
thor vous allez cliquer sur rechercher
et vous allez taper votre recherche
exact qui et comment perdre du vente
rapidement ça vous fait apparaître en
surbrillance le mot clé que vous
recherchez vous voyez très bien que par
exemple la toute première vidéo de kevin
philippe comment perdre du ventre
rapidement apparaît uniquement dans le
titre et pas dans la description ça veut
dire que si vous vous travaillez vous
mettez bien dans votre titre et il ya
moins de votre description vous avez une
carte à jouer
on va regarder ensuite thibault in shape
alors lui son appareil carrément nulle
part mais lui a un gros nombre d'abonnés
donc ça veut dire tout de suite il ya eu
une réaction donc on va pas le regarder
maigrir du ventre rapidement exercice il
ya neuf cent quarante cinq mille vu et
tout comment à une chaîne qui a combien
d'abonnés 126000 vue donc ça veut dire
qu'elle sait aussi référencé sur ce mot
clé donc à une vraie stratégie à mettre
en place par rapport à ces mots clés
vous prenez la vidéo après être belle
qui a fait 100 mille vue il ya onze mois
le mot-clé apparaît bien dans le titre
dans la description par contre excusez
moi mais la vignette elle incite pas du
tout à ce qu'on clique dessus donc je
pense que c'est pour ça que les vues
n'ont pas été très présent
d'autant plus que vous voyez là trente
mille abonnés ça ne marche pas ça c'est
typiquement un problème au niveau de la
vignette
il faut que vous ayez une vignette qui
parlent que votre mot clé soit dans
votre titre dans votre description et là
vous pourrez réussir maintenant ce qu'il
faut qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est est-ce
que ce cette requête comment perdre du
ventre rapidement est toujours recherché
est toujours d'actualité
là ce que vous allez faire c'est que
vous allez faire un copier coller vous
êtes dans google trends vous collez
votre
recherche et vous l'envoyez ça va vous
sortir un joli diagrammes et vous voyez
que tout de suite qu'il ya un volume de
recherche dans tous les pays bon on est
sur un terme français donc effectivement
on va utiliser à l'international et pas
uniquement france sur les douze derniers
mois dont toutes les catégories et sur
le web
on va affiner parce que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est youtube on va faire la
recherche sur youtube pour voir si c'est
très pertinent et stanley il ya quand
même un volume de recherche c'est pas
forcément là que vous aurez le plus gros
volume de recherche mais vous en avez un
on va comparer par exemple avec la
requête qui serait comment perdre du
ventre qui sera à mon avis plus
concurrentiel mais sur laquelle vous
pourrez réussir à vous positionner par
la suite voyez typiquement il ya un plus
grand volume de recherche si vous
arrivez à vous référencer sur comment
perdre du ventre rapidement vous avez de
fortes chances de réussir à vous
référencer sur comment perdre du ventre
une fabrique vidéo aura pris de
l'autorité aura pris des vues et vous
aurez augmenté en nombre d'abonnés
vous réussirez à vous référencer sur des
vidéos comme ça sur des termes comme
celle ci est même sûr perdre du ventre
qui à mon avis va être encore plus
difficile mais avec un bon volume de
recherche on va regarder voyait perdre
du ventre c'est encore mieux
et pour réussir à l'atteindre il faut
passer par différentes étapes par une
expression clé très longue
ensuite qui se raccourcit renforçant
vous prendrez de l'autorité et à la fin
vous pourrez travailler des teintes qui
seront beaucoup plus court voilà pour ce
qu'il en est autre chose qui peut être
très intéressante pour vous inspirer et
trouver les bonnes idées
vous allez dans google adwords adwords
vous allez dans outils vous allez dans
outils de planification de mots clés et
là vous allez taper le mot clé qui vous
intéresse pour trouver des idées par
rapport à vos vidéos alors là on va
taper l'expression la plus courte qui
est perdre du ventre qui nous intéresse
en réalité et
google adwords va nous suggérer des
idées pour travailler vos types de
vidéos
là on voit très bien qu'il ya quand même
un volume qui est intéressant perdre du
ventre c'est entre 10000 et 100000 de
volume de recherche moyenne mensuelle
c'est énorme
ensuite vous avez comment perdre du
ventre qui est aussi très très gros
maigrir du ventre qui intéressant
travail et ventre plat comment maigrir
du ventre
il voyait que là vous avez plein
d'inspiration pour trouver des termes
qui sont très sympas alors il ya autre
chose dira comment perdre du point qui
est aussi énorme
après vous pouvez ensuite allé sur idée
de groupe d'annonce là ça va vous les
classés par thématique comment maigrir
perdre rapidement ventre plat ventre
romeyer vitre
là ça vous fera des grandes familles par
exemple comment maigrir je clique dessus
et ça me propose des expressions clés
comment maigrir comment maigrir du
ventre comment maigrir des cuisses
comment maigrir du visage voilà un peu
comme au fond comment il faut
fonctionner et il faut que vous fassiez
exactement la même chose pour toutes vos
idées pour toutes vos thématiques
une fois que vous aurez réussi à faire
ça vous allez voir que vos vidéos vont
commencer à se positionner vous allez
monter dans les résultats de recherche
il faudrait ensuite réajusté si vous
voyez votre titre ne marche pas très
bien regarder ce qui bloque
est ce que par exemple comme sur cette
vignette là c'est votre vignettes qui
n'est pas cliquable
parce que même si votre titre vous aide
à vous référencer les gens cliquent non
pas parce qu'ils ont lu votre kit mais
parce qu'ils leur vignette vous a plu
vous prenez la vignette du dessous
perdre bas-ventre perdre le bas du
ventre
c'est une bonne vie n'y est pas ce que
vous avez tout de suite quelque chose de
bien alors vous voyez une nana qui
effectivement très bien très bien fait
très bien proportionné on comprend les
mots clés de façon dans tout ce qui est
bien c'est qu'il faut montrer ce sont
des modèles qui sont excusez moi bien
gaulée c'est ça qui est vendeur ça je
sais ça correspond à la réalité mais
c'est malheureusement beaucoup moins
vendeur et vous aurez beaucoup moins de
clics voilà un petit peu comment il faut
fonctionner n'hésitez pas à réajuster
inchangé vos miniature si vous voyez que
vous avez un taux de clics est très bas
n'hésitez pas à ajuster votre titre pour
bien vous positionnez m'étais bien une
bonne description dans laquelle on va
retrouver vos mots clés dans vos taxes
mettait des expressions qui
correspondent vraiment à votre recherche
comment perdre du ventre rapidement
comment perdre du ventre perdre du
ventre et tous les mots clés autour de
perdre
ventre pour ça je vous invite à aller
voir votre outil de planification nos
clés directement dans google adwords et
vous allez voir ça va extrêmement bien
vous aider par exemple pour votre vidéo
perdre du ventre vous mettez comment
perdre du ventre maigrir du ventre
ventre plat comment maigrir du ventre
comment maigrir mais gravitent perdre du
ventre rapidement perdre du ventre
perdre du ventre rapidement comment
perdre son ventre perdre du ventre
hommes comment perdre du poids voilà
perdre du ventre
il faut vraiment voilà vous allez
trouver toutes vos idées de taxes
directement dans google adwords des
idées de mots clés et vous allez voir
grâce à cette méthode qui est très
simple vous allez réussir
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous ont apporté des
éléments de réponse n'hésitez pas à me
laisser un jeu y pousse bleus si vous
avez appris plein de choses et que je
vous aider abonnez-vous à la chaîne si
vous voulez avoir toujours plus
d'informations pour savoir quelles sont
les bonnes stratégies et quelles sont
les bonnes pratiques à mettre en place
pour réussir sur youtube
n'hésitez pas à laisser les commentaires
si vous avez des questions sur la vidéo
je le ferais un plaisir des réponses
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
d'ici là portez vous bien ça lui
[Musique]